[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn ego garlic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen I am
pleased to introduce actor writer
musician
Grammy and Emmy winner one of the most
enduring entertainers of all time mr.
Steve Martin
and this is Alec boggle
but welcome to the 82nd annual Academy
Awards everyone wants an Oscar but
they're very hard to get that's right
Steve ballots are sent out to 6000
members of the Academy yes and then they
mark their ballots and then they are
tabulated by Price Waterhouse and then
no matter what they nominate Meryl
Streep Meryl Streep holds the record for
most nominations as an actress or as I
like to think of it
whereas I like to think of it most
losses
but the biggest change this year the
best picture category has doubled and
when that was announced all of us in
Hollywood thought the same thing
what's five times two and having ten
films is a good thing that means that
some movies can get attention that
ordinarily would not like the last
station Christopher Plummer nominated
for Best Supporting at
how what's that movie about it's about
Leo Tolstoy and his wife Sofia Oh Alec
you should have said spoiler alert and I
know you loved Invictus I did because it
combines two of your favorite passions
rugby and tensions between blacks and
whites
oh look there's Vera Farmiga the co-star
up up in the air
did I pronounce that right up in the air
oh and look there's that damn Helen
Mirren
see that's Dean Mira
and right there in the front row is
Meryl Streep
we were just talking about you when
Steve and I met her at the start of our
movie gets complicated we both want the
same thing what a memorable threesome
anyone who has ever worked with Meryl
Streep always ends up saying the exact
same thing can that woman act and what's
up with all the Hitler memorabilia
[Applause]
and here is the cast of the nominated
film precious Wow
I love that precious was nominated
because to me it's the one film that
really lived up to its video game
in precious Gabourey Sidibe has told
she's worthless nobody likes her that
she has no future hey I'm with CAA - you
know Gabourey and I have something in
common in our first movies we were both
born a poor black child
and behind her is Monique what a great
performance and this could be a first
Steve Monique is a stand-up comedian and
they just don't give Oscars to stand-up
comedians like anyone has to tell you
that where is Dario what an actor woody
it's so great to see you here tonight
you had to hit movies Zombieland and
nominated for the messenger
congratulations woody it's a great
career he's so high
oh wait a minute now is that the
director of Avatar James Cameron
yes it is did you know Steve that that
cutaway of James Cameron has already
earned three million dollars he's on a
roll
avatar has taken movies to a new level
of imagination and stunning visuals oh
look it's the floating wood sprites from
Avatar the seeds from the tree of souls
the considered very pure and sacred
spirits
you know how that gets an amazing fact
that James Cameron used to be married to
the director of another nominated film
The Hurt Locker Kathryn Bigelow
she was so pleased to be nominated with
him she sent him a beautiful gift basket
with a timer Oh
and he reciprocated by sending her a
Toyota
oh look there's George Clooney
[Applause]
Plus
now over here is the inglorious basterds
section and over here are the people who
made the movie
heyy and inglorious basterds Christoph
Waltz played a Nazi obsessed with
finding Jews world creased stuff
the motherlode
Steve an interesting fact
why did you know that the moustache Brad
Pitt wore an inglorious basterds was the
same one that selma hayek wore in
freedom i did not know that and there
there's the beautiful Sandra Bullock who
doesn't love Sandra Bullock well tonight
we may find out
oh my god there's Matt Damon oh you know
what I heard if Matt Damon wins he's
going to take Jennifer Garner to Tahiti
to celebrate no that's Ben Affleck Ben
Affleck is married to Jennifer Garner
you are so naive
all right who's next
well Steve some of the younger stars are
here tonight Zac Efron and Taylor
Lautner
take a good look at us guys this is you
in five years
[Applause]
and oh there is Jeff Bridget
what a great career nominated five times
and again tonight for Best Actor
who else has nominated for Best Actor
Alec well there's
now it's time to get on with the awards
and if you'd like a transcript of
tonight's show then you should really
think about getting a life